hello and welcome to this video on
playing craft souq powerful move would
be the one to one translation so I know
this looks a little bit odd but it has
an idea the idea of this move is to
transpose into a Slav exchange that
happens quite frequently like if they
take here play d5 and oftentimes people
who play 9003 c5 have no clue about the
Slav exchange and I experienced this in
many games that they have problems
handling these positions it's this is a
this has a lot more let's say drops of
poison than people believe and he's
taking a lot of time already and this is
bad him this is already in bad after
Queen b3 now like black has no decent
moves now because yeah well you have a
hard time to cover these two and b6
should not work due to think eform right
before is the problem
one nightly five and then if all there
are there are ways to merely kill black
after b6 yeah but this this gives me d5
them let's take it
Queen b3 906 and yeah here I think I
think this is not this is not a loss yam
form for black but it is not good I
think he can still can still fight in
this position
I thought Bishop c2 would be the thing
but not entirely certain anyway let's
see I probably have to be a little bit a
little bit more modest here in my
development Bishop f4 is this a bit too
a bit too slow
okay so is he going for night before
maybe
I should just castle then yeah as you
see it's not it's not super simple to
win I mean it's a pawn but there are
still technical obstacles Bishop c2
maybe no
okay yeah I wonder if rook c4 is an idea
trying to try to push the night away
there from before
this is actually not a bad move I'm
covering all the sensitive squares and
like d3 and c2 and I still have or not I
still have I have Bishop f3 attacking b7
so yeah that's not bad looks like a
fairly clean solution him also makes you
see for a little bit more interesting
actually okay maybe he didn't have any
any good move does this now looks quite
strong he does not want to take the
knight as hanging it doesn't have
squares really and my next movers took a
c1 and if he has to take C foyer I'm
just now I've got my pawn structure I
got a good pawn structure again and can
now slowly go to convert this that was
actually a very unnecessary move I could
have played c5 immediately yeah
immediately c5 was definitely stronger
okay it's not a problem but it was a
stronger way to play it's still super
convenient position to play so do we go
b5 yeah maybe test this nice tempo
quality due to the check and now if I
take
yeah I think it's actually good because
I have this I can enter the position
immediately would be one would be one
rooks e7 Bishop a5 / d7 c6 close to
winning very close but okay it's enough
okay it's Bishop a5 actually useful news
and not really right he doesn't have
anything useful here King these seven
Bishop a5 is even better
yeah and now this move Bishop a5 d7
takes King tags yeah I can just bring
the King up that looks odd it's not not
like he's got anything good oh I'm
taking this okay
that's the cleanest one just winning the
winning the piece okay
yeah that was basically exactly what c3
is about you want to trick people into
the Slav that they don't know and yeah
here a six or nine c6 is the normal move
after Bishop f5 it already is a bit
tricky for black I think probably
bestest respect going back here that's
what they usually recommend I mean not
that line should be avoided but once
black is there is probably the best
option after Queen b6 I can just grab
this even though it has a little bit of
a compensation maybe it's not super
super obvious that say that when white
should win so what happens if he takes
this for example Bishop d2 is right okay
so I can do this because that has no
squares yeah that is that makes a lot of
sense
yeah it's important there those things
are important and I think I have to play
a little bit more modestly 83m what's
the engine likes my plane
it's there's nothing special but you
have to have to do it rook c1 yeah and
now I think 91 is a move I liked the
engine wants to go Knight e5 but I like
this quality that everything is covered
that's always nice and he doesn't really
have anything great after this it's
basically basically over here c5 I
thought is stronger b3 was kind of
unnecessary like it pushes the knight
back as well and then I've got deform
but okay it's not a mistake really just
huge advantage in a technical position
now he does not get rid of the b-pawn he
has to cover it passively so yeah it's a
purely technical and simple simple win
basically the engine gives a couple of
question marks here but it doesn't
doesn't really matter it it's lost
already yeah
gives me zero zero zero so always good
to see if you are not a cheater
like have 9 and incentive pornos
but in those kind of technical openings
you can sometimes manage those cos that
looks like cheating because it's so it's
very difficult to make a mistake in a in
a way ok guys thanks for watching